sorry hello and welcome to Zeo playing
as Selby's love serbian stuff heading
before with the draw it seems you can
actually when you go here you see the
game that's funny so you can actually
would be able to look up what you had
played against him before interesting
yeah he's going I'm sorry for a sideline
here in the Scotch for Knights yeah that
looks spectacular but I don't think it
is that great where do I go though I
mean I have to take of course but now
where do I go on
Queen to d3 I guess
yeah there's always the sceptical trick
or trick is a bit strong the idea Bishop
takes Bishop takes Queen takes Queen
takes yeah you can I think you can
cancel here actually cancel
[Music]
okay but let's think about this for a
moment
95 is also 95 then Bishop d2 probably
yeah come on that must be right no
matter what night if for one night
before or de for 94
yeah isn't 94 a good move I have a hard
time to believe it isn't what do I have
something else Queen takes this rook e1
and Knight takes I have bishop before
you cannot take line because of mate on
D aid in fact Knight takes Queen d8 that
is almost working and Knight takes Queen
d8 Bishop g5 double check King c7 bishop
net is all it's almost working but not
quite okay so here I can take with the
Queen as I have the maid threat anyhow I
just wonder if Knight takes is better
and probably not yeah evil people just
cancel I guess okay and now is there
anything better than Knight takes f6 I
have Knight d6 but it's a bit tough to
believe that this is better it could be
could be a self wedding situation so
this is the simplest way to do it maybe
not the best and maybe not the best I'm
willing I'm willing to give her to admit
that it could not be the best
yeah the 8 is probably enough to to
equalize for black I'm a little bit more
active with that Bishop that is quite
nice but it's nothing really important
Rock the 8 maybe walk this 7 azimuth
that's an interesting idea
ok maybe he has seen that um anyway what
to do now he might just want to play b5
that's definitely possible
Oh looky area just the simple rookie age
yeah nothing much going on my rookie aid
actually is a bit annoying now that I
look at it a little bit more
I don't quite know what you go with the
Queen and there is always Queen g5 and
Cunha for business ok this one yeah this
is the keep it simple method but of
course I've got absolutely zilch which
is completely equal
there any way to do anything probably
Nadia McQueen is a tad more active but
this is just so little
yeah I think he's playing this correctly
yeah doing doing this but the King makes
sense maybe some f5 even and the King is
active it's not bad
maybe he can go to d1
eight seconds whoops I didn't see that
one King edge six would be a mate so
that won't happen I'll probably have to
make the drone now just want to check
quickly if yeah I don't think I can't do
anything more yeah that wasn't that was
a bit that wasn't rolling Radia not
happy about it I should get something
out of this opening like here I should
get something maybe I did something
wrong here because this is definitely
not going to be this not good you know
but maybe I have to go to e3 and the
engines has to go to e3 I could not
remember exactly in the same position
like in the game but here I'm preventing
d5 simply by natural means of being able
to take you know yeah and then this is
this is fine yeah I mean it's a very
nice position you have to see that this
is bad it's a typical motif in this line
where the pressure here is mounting
quickly you've got ideas like that and
black is not in good shape Ian the
activity is too much and you get the
same you can get the same position like
from d3 but the problem is that you can
do this here d5 and I don't have a
refutation I tried with cancelling but
it doesn't it doesn't quite work yeah
it's funny by the way if you look at 94
to check this move it doesn't work yeah
but now it's just a funny motif the
double check and this actually would be
made by TKO here
yeah and now out of ideas I think so if
he would have played night before I
would have taken on before and I'm now
I'm threatening this so castles Bishop
e1 was
planned and this seems to be fine for
him as well so I have to go to e3 yeah
an tiem you're just you're a little bit
better maybe with white but I probably
have to go to this exam I kind of had
this hunch during the game but I
couldn't quite bring myself to do it it
can be can be a really naughty self and
I saw that this is not possible due
tonight f7 but it's still yeah yeah
maybe I have to do it that was probably
too simplistic I mean it looks like
white is a bit quicker on the files but
it really isn't the case and I think
after this move rook e8 would have
gotten me into trouble yeah and the
could the engine confirms look e8 Queen
d2 and he had the end there is this
chick yeah I saw that
yeah now it's just nothing yeah I have
this symbolic advantage with the with
the more active Queen but of course we
cannot win a game with this okay guys
thanks for watching